42 recession-proof money secrets and if
you don't know who I am on his Oxford
Mosey I sold two of my companies last
year for 46.2 million and my current
portfolio at acquisition.com is over 200
million dollars a year and I want to
take 10 years of money secrets that
worked in both boom and bust economies
so that you can save the decade and
apply them today number one he who gives
the money has the power so a lot of
times poor people they're always trying
to get money I was trying to get money
the person who gives the money is the
one who's in control like if you think
about the biggest institutions in the
world what are they Banks what do they
do all day they give money when you give
someone money you get to dictate the
terms you actually now own them number
two never trade reputation for money
because you can get money back but you
can't get reputation back if you think
about reputation as something that
compounds over time the longer you have
it the more you build it the more it
compounds unto itself it is your brand
which allows you to do more deals do
bigger deals do them faster the moment
you lose the rep because you traded it
for money in the short you cut the
compounding and that's where all of the
gains in life come from number three
money love speed wealth loves time
poverty loves indecision micro money
love speed if you want to move quickly
on faster customers follow up with your
leads Etc when you think about Building
Wealth it's not about transacting it's
about letting that compounding happen
and that takes time and it takes not
interrupting it most people never
achieve either of those things because
they sit in decision four we can always
make more money than we need this is a
belief that has served my wife and I
really really well we look back on our
lives and we've never not been able to
eat not had shelter and we've continued
to increase our skill set a lot of times
we have this desire or you know our
animal brain wants to make us make
decisions out of scarcity out of fear we
don't need any of the money that's
coming because we have always had enough
fortunes are made by taking a lot of
risk with a little bit of money and
fortunes are maintained by taking a
little bit of risk with a lot of money
somebody who's self-made had nothing and
so they risked everything in order to
make it big but the thing is when you
have nothing you're not risking a lot
you have nothing to lose which makes you
dangerous which is one of the biggest
advantages of having nothing but if you
continue to do that when you do have
something to lose you can lose your
fortune and so you have to change the
behavior once you have the cast once you
have the Empire six money flows where
attention goes if you spend time
thinking about fashion all day your
attention is going towards buying
clothes if you think about cars all day
it's going towards your car if you're
thinking about your business all day it
should be going towards your business
pick one thing go all in because you
only have so much Juju think about it
like a magnifying glass and you're the
sun in this instance and you've got to
burn a hole to get through to the next
level if you're a spread across too thin
of an area you never get enough
concentrated heat most people have the
potential but they don't have the focus
which is why they can never break
through seven your home life and your
business life have to be aligned
money-wise so you can't try to grow a
business and like reinvest everything
here while you're living a super lavish
lifestyle trying to flex like it has to
be aligned all of our business rules
around money are also our home rules
around money and so if we don't live
with any debt within our personal lives
we do the same thing within our business
lives eight ignore money advice from
poor people this may sound ridiculous
but let me say it differently ignore
money advice from your Dad or Mom who
are poorer than you want to be from your
good friends who are poorer than you
want to be from people who have smaller
dreams for your life than you do the
reason that rich people can lose
everything and then recreate it is
because they see reality more accurately
the reason people can't make money is
because they don't see reality the way
it actually is most of life is trying to
pull these rocks out of our vision so
that we can see more clearly nine it's
always easier to buy than to sell you
want to get into a stock you want to get
into something you can buy it instantly
you want to get into a real estate deal
you want to get into a business you have
to be extra careful you want to put all
the slow on the buy and you want to put
all the lubricant on the cell 10 money
is fickle money is jealous it sticks and
goes to the person who pays it the most
attention money comes into the system
but there are these grooves in the
ground where it all eventually flows up
to the few people who pay at the most
attention someone gets paid they go buy
their groceries the grocery person has
to go by for the supplier supplier buys
them from whatever working with the
person who has the access is the one who
pays it the most attention is the one
who it sticks to at the end 11. we stay
poor until we've learned all the lessons
that poverty has to teach people stay in
poverty but they're not trying to pay
attention to like what lesson do I need
to be learning that I'm not actually
taking action learning how to save money
at a basic level personal finance let's
be guys it's Graham here these are the
lessons that we have to learn in poverty
to get out of poverty and until you do
that you don't beat the level 12.
frugality drives Innovation even when
you have money one of the best things to
do in my opinion is constrain your
resources constrain time it'll force you
to think creatively to solve problems
without using money as the solution and
if you have constraints right now on
time and or money don't see it as a
disadvantage because it's what people
who do have money try to get into to
solve problems and the only thing that's
at the disadvantage is thinking it is
13. think once before investing think
twice before spending investing is
something that you're putting money into
that is going to give you a return of
some kind it's either going to give you
a skill that's going to increase your
earning capacity or it's going to be
something that's going to quite
literally give you a return in terms
it's going to be yield or worth more in
the future spending is something that's
going to never be worth more in the
future and it's going to be consumed 14
money flows to the person who needs it
the least the risk get richer because
they don't need it and because they
don't need it they have leverage you
have to sell not from your own wallet
but from the person in front of you come
to the table with our other options it's
the person who needs nothing who's the
person who has the most power and that's
where the money will go 15. we make
money our money does not make us you
start tying your self-worth to your net
worth then your net worth itself becomes
a liability to your own self-esteem it
is my ability to make money which is
what creates my value not the money
itself because the money itself can be
taken my family was in the Iranian
Revolution and everything they had was
taken all it takes is one government
saying oh all that land all those cars
all those homes those are ours now and
that's it and so a lot of people have
this idea of legacy and permanence
That's Just an Illusion which is why we
make our money our money doesn't make us
16. it may be an amazing opportunity but
not our amazing opportunity one of the
things that I needed early on was
permission to not do things because in
the beginning you don't know how to do
anything your analysis paralysis and you
just get scared and once you get over
that the problem is that your yes muscle
becomes too flexed you start saying yes
to everything we should do this thing
and we should do this thing together you
say dude I think it's amazing
opportunity I just don't think it's my
amazing opportunity and it's gotten me
out of so many situations that I know
long term wouldn't have been good for me
17. we control the money flow wherever
possible people who have a lot of
control payment processors everybody
thinks they're amazing until the day you
can't process money and so the idea is
the further Upstream you can go the more
leverage and control you have over the
money Banks get the money and then they
give it back later the person who's
furthest Upstream the money has the most
power over it 18 always have no
fund me knowing that I can take whatever
risk I want and I am still protected and
everything that I have for the rest of
my life is taken care of gives me a lot
of Peace which allows be more aggressive
be more offensive as soon as you can
have your oh phone whether it's
three months whether it's six months
start putting that away that nut so that
you can go more on the offensive 19. the
biggest erodor of wealth is ignorance
not knowing how to make a million
dollars is costing you whatever you make
every year minus a million dollars and
so if you make 50 Grand a year it costs
you 950 000 a year to not know how to
make a million dollars which is why I
put so much money into paying down this
invisible hand that's been suppressing
my income my whole life and yours too
20. you get paid for the value you
create times your ability to negotiate
divided by how hard you are to replace
if you provide something that's very
valuable and you're very good at
negotiating but somebody else can
provide the exact same thing as you for
a tenth of the price you still don't
have that good of a negotiating position
making money is capturing a percentage
of the value that you create for other
people 21 mistakes love a rush decision
I've trained myself now enough that like
when I feel fomo I pause fomo means slow
go mistakes love a rush decision and so
it's just one of those easy beliefs that
has slowed me down and has saved me so
much money 22. leverage comes from not
needing the other person and more
specifically leverage comes from needing
nothing you can't control somebody who
needs nothing
right someone needs nothing you have no
influence over them how do I become that
person the monks do it by relinquishing
everything and needing nothing and the
rich man does it by satisfying all his
needs and not needing the deal on the
other side of the table in both of those
situations you create leverage 23
markets take longer to adjust than you
expect and then they move faster than
you can imagine The Big Short if you saw
that movie the guy was shorting for like
four years and he's like the math
doesn't make sense the bubble kept going
bubble kept going bubble kept going and
then it happened faster than people
imagine we have to be comfortable with
the fact that we might have to sit in
discomfort for an extended period of
time before what we believe to be
reality is reflected 24 money is a game
treated as such you can't win the game
if you don't know you're playing one the
wealthiest people in the world see money
as a game they don't even use money to
satisfy material needs because they
already have it how can I adopt that
perspective earlier on in my career
thinking about things in terms of
personal bests bank account PRS what
gets measured gets improved you can get
someone to lose weight just by simply
getting them to weigh themselves every
day without giving them any advice at
all just if you pay attention to it it
will start sticking to you 25 don't bet
the empire for a pot of gold even though
you might have this opportunity here
it's never worth risking the whole pie
and I can't tell you the amount of times
where I've been like man if I went all
in on this thing money-wise the thing is
that you can go all in on your attention
but I wouldn't go all in on your money
26 always do a starter deal with new
faces so this is a hard one one of your
friends comes to you and is like dude I
want to do this Airbnb thing or hey I've
got this do a starter deal first you got
to see how these people are everything
should still look great on paper
everything should still make sense they
should still be amazing characters Etc
you still mitigate your risk by saying
first deal I'm gonna do with you is a
small deal 27 trust is worth more than a
bigger return trust lubricates deal
velocity trust compounds you don't want
to take all the meat on the bone because
you want to have a long-term
relationship when I talk to Partners
when I talk to business owners how they
talk about the people that they do
business with tells you a lot about them
and how they do business when I talk to
somebody and I'm like hey why don't you
do this they're like hey these guys have
been good to us for a very long time
we've had a very good relationship for
10 years that is something I respect a
lot and that is what people who have
money act like poor people always trying
to one over everyone over and over again
and they never get any trust from
anybody which means they have no
compounding relationships 28 money is
not a zero-sum game the older I've
gotten the more I'm like how can I get
onto their side of the table and both
make money together why don't we both
take a big piece of this upside rather
than slice up a pie that's in front of
us 29 never take a standard deal there's
always a better one there's always a
better deal and a lot of times you have
to ask for it hey this term and this
term and this term are things that are
concerning to me is there anything we
can do about these remember earlier
leverage comes from not needing the deal
you have to be willing to walk away and
I can't tell you the amount of times
that I've walked away from a deal and
the person comes back after saying well
I can't do a deal I'm like cool no
worries and they come back three or four
days later and they're like all right
man I'll do the deal and then I might be
like hey well the terms have changed you
know I'm kidding 30. expect low risk
amazing Returns the wealthiest friends
that I have who are billionaire plus
they're just not interested in 10 20
returns they're looking for 50 plus
annualized returns most people expect 10
because that's what the s p does it
doesn't mean that that has to be your
personal standard thinking through that
way has changed how I saw investing in
general 31 don't think in irr which
means internal rate of return instead
thinking how long will this take to
double how long will this take to Triple
it's hard to say this is going to grow
by 25 a year what is easier to say is
this is going to double in three
changing how you ask the question
changes how you'll find the answer 32
this is a buffetism but diversification
is a hedge against ignorance and it's
only risky if you don't know what you're
doing there's a million games and all of
them make tons of money and so it's
really about taking one game and taking
it to its natural conclusion which is
learning every single aspect of that
game rather than saying I want to be in
stocks I want to be in real estate I
want to be in crypto I would also have
my side hustles I want to like you can't
get good at any even because you're
competing against people who are all in
play one game and play well 34. I
skipped 33 because I covered it in that
last one returns are in the terms
everybody who's watching this if you
make money doing anything that's inside
us on I'll pay you a billion dollars for
your business but it's on my terms and I
can make that deal every time and not
lose money understanding the terms of
the agreement and how many different
ways you can make terms and the only way
you do that is through having the
conversations and trying to structure it
from learning from other people 35
whenever possible use house money if you
have the opportunity to recoup your
principal and still have money in the
game do that then you can get super
aggressive with the Investments and
things like that that you're making but
you're doing it on a house money you're
doing it with no chance of losing
principle 36 always know how to get your
money back you have to know the exact
way of doing it not just like oh yeah I
can get my money back she's like no but
but how would I do it walk me through
each of the steps so that I have full
understanding of how this would work if
they actually don't mean it then they
won't have a way to do it you'll be able
to sniff something out immediately 37
cash flow is King all right and that's
both on a personal level and on a
business level so for you your cash
flows can be dictated by your income
minus your expenses it's really your
savings slow if there's one thing that
you get from Money Rules is that you'll
be switching your metric towards what am
I saving every month rather than what am
I making every month 38 buy for Forever
This is a warrant confident in Charlie
mungerism Charlie said the money isn't
made in the buy or the sell it's made in
the weight if you could never sell
anything you buy when you are buying you
could never get out of it then you buy
differently and you buy super long and
then ultimately that's what doesn't
interrupt the compounding process and
that's what unlocks huge wealth later 39
you heard me say it earlier but fomo
means go slow you feel fomo it means
slow down it means take a second give a
breather put some space between you and
the decision the only reason you feel
fomo is because your time rest is too
short 40. if you can't afford to lose
the money then don't use the money if
you're like this is my last dollar then
it's probably not a good idea to risk it
right which is why we always have the oh
fund 41 peace of mind can be bought
and it can be sold if there are
situations where you're like man this is
going to keep me up at night don't do it
peace of mind can very much be bought
and sold and I can tell you make much
better decisions when you've got it 42
and final a lot of people think about
diversification in terms of industry but
they don't think about it in terms of
capital stack a bank for example is at
the top it's a preferred creditor it's a
reason a lot of banks don't money and
it's because they're the first creditors
so you can think about diversification
between like stocks crypto businesses
whatever you can also think about it
vertically in terms of where am I
sitting on the stack if you think about
those in terms of both types of
diversification When the tide goes out
you're the one who gets your money back
first